Before we go we like to say a ha.
Ha, ha.
We like to play a quick round of.
Drewth or Dare.
(audience clapping)
And today we have Jasmine.
Hi Jasmine.
Hi.
You look so great.
Thank you.
All right, and now you can choose a Drewth or a dare.
What's it gonna be?
Drewth.
Okay, hit us.
I would want Viola Davis to play me
if there was ever a movie about my life
who would each of you would want,
who each of you would like to play in your life movie?
That's such a great question.
This is hard, I mean,
I'm just gonna say what everyone's thinking.
Meryl Streep, right, Meryl Streep?
(audience laughing and clapping)
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It could work.
It could honestly work.
No, it could, I'm laughing 'cause I'm like,
"She could do it."
Yeah, well I'll tell you right now,
it's a role of a lifetime Meryl,
congratulations, your next Oscar.
I don't know who, I want someone funny
'cause I like funny.
I don't want some heavy bird.
It's gotta be someone beautiful, kind, smart.
I said funny silly, but thank you.
Well no, I was just thinking,
I kinda sound like I'd be born for the role, right?
Shall we just play each other?
Yeah, how about that?
I'll play Ross, he'll play me
and we'll just call it a day.
God, that's such a good question.
You know who could do it?
Mary-Louise Parker.
Oh, I love Mary-Louise.
Me too.
She's the best.
Yeah, we do.
Well, she can do anything.
I know.
Alright, well, gosh.
I think this one's gonna haunt me all day and night.
She's gonna text me 2:00 AM.
I am, I am by the way.
Maybe I'll get your number too, Jasmine.
(upbeat music)